on se retrouve aujourd'hui chez samsung
pour parler de deux nouveaux produits de
nouveaux produits principaux il ya plein
de nouveaux produits qui sont présentés
mais il a surtout deux qui vont nous
intéresser le tout premier il est juste
ici c'est le samsung galaxy note 20 qui
a succédé au galaxy note 10 je pense que
vous en douterez il ya un côté un peu
logique là dedans et puis on a surtout
l'arrivée d'un modèle qui va choix
intéressant c'est le note 20 ultra à
l'année dernière on avait nos dix ne
disent plus cette année ayant changement
de nom du côté de chez simple autres une
évolution on l'a vieux que la gamme s
20s 20s 20 plus elle se bat ultra là il
n'y a pas de modèle plus a été retirée
on a le note 20 le note 20 ultra le note
20 va être l'évolution de la gamme de
par excellence avec le note un peu
standard bien que passant d'art parce
que beaucoup de choses et on va se
raconter tout ça dans quelques instants
et puis ensuite on a eu notre vin ultras
qui est l'excellence chez samsung avec
un style est plutôt cool on a donc deux
smartphones qui sont dans la même adn
mais qui ont chacun leurs
caractéristiques propres
on va donc regarder quelles sont ces
différences est ce que ces modèles sont
intéressants vers lequel il faut aller
d'ailleurs dit moi tout de suite en bas
en commentaire ci en est un qui vous
branche plutôt qu il ya une petite
différence c'est que là vous allez me de
photos sur l'ultra qui est quand même un
peu plus proéminent mais qui est très
très très très cool qui est quand même
assez épais 1
franchement il est très épais mais je
trouve vraiment vraiment super sympa et
puis sur le note 20 vous avez quelque
chose est un peu plus petit un peu plus
discret un peu plus profil et on reste
dans la gamme note donc en gamme des
smartphones qui sont très grands des
smartphones avec hespel puisque ici le
style et s'appelle le s pen
on les retrouve d'un côté comme de
l'autre mais avant toute chose et c'est
pas déjà fait j invite à venir vous
abonner parce que je présente et bien
effectivement et bien toutes les
nouveautés smartphone vous parle
également de monde de table etc si ce
n'est pas déjà fait vous cliquez sur le
petit bouton vous avez juste ici rouge
comme ça vous saurez tout vous êtes
sonner la cloche et vous serez notifié
dès qu'une nouvelle vidéo rivera et ça
c'est génial je sais pas si vous êtes
coutumier de la gamme note chez samsung
on est vraiment sur l'idée de la
productivité c'est l'adn de cette gamme
elle reste particulière elle vient petit
peu se démarquer de ce qu'on retrouve
ailleurs chez samsung vous avez
notamment la gamme s qui est axé sur la
photo sur le très haut de gamme dans le
meilleur de ce que sait faire samsung la
gamme note bien évidemment c'est la
productivité c'est le style et ça reste
une tâche qui est un peu niche et je
suis pas sûr tout le monde à utiliser un
stylet mais par contre ce que peuvent
faire ce que peuvent faire
à plusieurs c'est galaxy note 20 et
notre vin ultra est vraiment extrêmement
cool et même si vous n'êtes pas
forcément très intéressé par le côté
stylet et bien sachez qu'avec ces
produits là vous avez une proposition de
valeur qui est vraiment bien fait vous
avez des productions très bien fini un
produit qui est vraiment temps adressé à
la productivité aux personnes qui
veulent bien prendre des notes
travailler avec la notion du decs pour
le pisé comme un petit ordinateur sans
aucun problème ça c'est bien l'idée de
la productivité pour la création la
création vidéo il ya un gros focus qui a
été fait là dessus effectivement sur la
gamme s est bien les plus sur l'idée de
la photo et là on est vraiment sur
l'idée de la photo et de la vidéo je
vous développez dans quelques instants
puisque derrière vous avez également de
la performance et puis c'est aussi un
smartphone qui est axé sur le gaming
avec une très très belle collaboration
avec microsoft donc ça c'est aussi
extrêmement cool un produit qui est
vraiment très complet que je trouve très
intéressant
alors après on est vraiment dans deux
univers je vous dis d'un côté le note 20
il intéressant mais le petit bémol que
je vais apporter c'est au niveau de
l'écran alors samsung pas si vous savez
fabriquent eux mêmes leur propre écran
ont toujours de très très très beaux
écrans mais cela devint il a un truc un
petit peu différent au delà de la taille
au delà du format c'est que vous avez un
smartphone avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 60 hertz contre 120
m de l'autre côté alors si vous n'êtes
pas coutumier à l'idée du 60d s120 ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que ça va être
le nom d' images qui vont s'afficher par
seconde plus vous en avez plus est
fluide plus c'est cool c'est un peu
l'idée l'idée d'avoir un smartphone qui
coûte elle est pas loin de 1000 euros
voire 1000 euros on va dire ça comme ça
60 hertz aujourd'hui me 2020 ça fait un
petit peu râler malgré tout l écran est
de bonne qualité d'une très belle
proposition
mais voyez c'est un peu le petit bémol
que je vais venir apporter sur le côté
multimédia
là par contre vous avez un écran wqs des
plus vous avez une excellente résolution
avec un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz donc là l'expérience en termes de
gaming en termes de multimédia en termes
de navigation et bien ça va être toute
autre chose et c'est vraiment maximiser
on est dans l'ultra donc les l'ultra
cesco fait de mieux c'est ce qui est
plus est on retrouve vraiment là-dessus
sur galaxy s vous allez avoir trois
couleurs ça c'est le mystique green cet
hiver qui est très sympa avec le stylet
qui exactement de la même couleur donc
ça c'est cool on a également le mystique
gré et puis on a le moustique bros alors
les trois ont un dôme at ça évite les
traces de doigts plutôt sympa c'est
efficace tandis que l'autre côté vous
allez effectivement retrouvé sur le
modèle ultra
le mystique bronze toujours en hâte vous
avez un smartphone avec un dos blanc qui
lui par contre n'est pas du tout le
match et va prendre les traces de doigts
mais une fois de plus un smartphone que
vous allez venir protéger donc c'est pas
très grave mais vous avez également un
smartphone noir alors il a des
faussaires un peu de bleu tu es
peut-être moi qui rêve mais je vois ça
comme ça est lui par contre pour la les
traces de doigts pour faire de l'art
tout ce que voulait tout faire des
petits dessins avec votre transpiration
pour y ait un côté un peu sympathique
aux yeux en quête d'un smartphone il
faut bien évidemment venir protéger
aller sur le site de mon partenaire
rhinochill pour découvrir l'ensemble des
solutions notamment les coptes fait pour
votre galaxy note 20 galaxy note 20
ultra vous ai mis un petit lien en bas
dans la description allait venir cliquer
pour tout découvrir et vous inscrire
pour avec les premiers au courant dès la
sortie de ses produits pour votre
smartphone vous allez avoir différents
types de codes différents types de
protections et croyez moi un smartphone
comme ça c'est extrêmement important de
venir le protège est surtout pour
honorer dans des smartphones à 1000
euros voire un peu plus de 1000 euros ça
serait dommage de venir les endommager
qui dit samsung galaxy note dit très
très grand smartphone ça je pense que
vous vous en douterez sur le galaxy note
vous avez un écran de 6,7 pouces c'est
un écran plat ça vraiment la différence
entre les deux vaille celui ci il est
complètement que là on essaie résolution
full hd plus de 1400 par 1080 pixels à
394 pixels par pouce
et c'est un ratio vingt neuvième tandis
que sur le note 20 ultra vous avez un
très grand terrien je sais pas si vous
voyez bien il ya des reflets je suis
fait pour le mémoire un des jolis
reflets on à l'écran le 6 juin 9 pouces
c'est un écran incurvé
on le voit bien sur le côté très sympa
j'aime bien côté la banque est très très
premium sur cet écran là c'est du wqs
des plus 3888 par mille 400 pixels à 496
pixels par pouce et je le dis avec un
tour après schisme en de 120 hertz et un
ratio également de vingt neuvième
il ya aussi une différence en termes de
protection sur le galaxy note vous avez
un verre corning gorilla glass 5 à
l'avant tandis que sur l'autre vous
allez avoir un verre corning gorilla
glass est à l'avant mais également au
dos parce que oui ici sur l'ultra au dos
vous avez du verre tandis que sur le
note 20 et bien c'est pas du verre c'est
du plastique haut doubs alors on va pas
se dire plastique plastic en pas partir
en courant pas du tout parce que on a un
plastique qui a vraiment en effet
premium qui a même un effet un peu métal
et si je vous l'avais pas dit je pense
que vous l'auriez pas devine d'ailleurs
dit moi comment vous le trouvez est ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
bartois effectivement un gros module
photo on va voir ici l'emplacement du
spn alors là il ya une différence par
rapport à ce qu'on avait une dernière
l'emplacement du respect n'a changé
côté à cause du blog photos qui prend
beaucoup plus de place on a toujours le
capteur d'empreintes digitales
ultrasonique à ultrasons qui va
extrêmement vite on a un produit qui est
bien prise en main qui est bonne je vous
le dis une fois de plus sa gamme note on
est sur des grands produits donc on le
voit ici vous allez l'utiliser à demain
mais on reste dans cette idée là du
grand smartphone de la productivité du
confort de visionnage et on va pas se
retrouver avec un petit smartphone qui
tient pas beaucoup de place un
smartphone qui forcément être un peu
plus lourd le note 20 fera 198 grimpe à
10 que le note 20 ultra fera 213 g et
puis très honnêtement tenant comme ça
bon absolument rien de choquant on a ici
des écrans qui sont compatibles hd yaris
plus vraiment très bonne qualité on les
sort du dynamic amoled au niveau du nod
20 ultra tandis qu'on est sur du super
amoled du côté du nôtre 20 bon pour moi
y'a rien déconnant tout ça on ne
regardera on ira plus loin lors des
phases de test là pour l'instant on est
vraiment sur une découverte du produit
puisqu'on parle ici d'idées de gaming 10
des performances on en trouve un exil en
1990 109,20 vous avez 8 gigas de ram
tandis que son noces valtra vous avez
uniquement un smartphone 5 g comme on
avait sur le s20 ultra c'est uniquement
de la saint dié parce que c'est ce qu'on
retrouve de mieux donc vous aurez douzy
à g en termes de stockage sur le dos de
vin vous avez 256 go de stockage non
extensible tandis que sur le note 20
ultra vous avez soit 256 go de stockage
soit 512 extensible grâce à une carte
microsd pour aller jusqu'à un terrain
bon je n'ai pas testé en termes de
performance je le vois je le bats
tournait jour effectivement qu'il est
plutôt réactif on est serein et xaus 990
ans on connaît il n'y a rien de bien
neuf là dessus donc on est sur une
machine qui tournera et keira gars on
n'ira pas aussi loin que sont des
instincts dragoon 865 ou 865 plus mais
en termes de performances pour de la
productivité pour de guémy on est dans
ce qui se fait de mieux les vraiment
dans le haut du panier donc on aura
vraiment une machine extrêmement
réactive qui va vraiment bien pouvoir
vous accompagner et réagir à tous vos
besoins extrêmement rapidement alors
puisqu'on parle effectivement de
performance ans parlait ici gaming parce
que c'est un usage qui se développe de
plus en plus est ces produits là font
pas du tout exception puisque en plus
vous avez un partenariat avec microsoft
garder ça est-ce que c'est pas tout
mignon ça c'est un contrôleur qu'on va
pouvoir utiliser spécialement sur vos
samsung galaxy note vint l'idée c'est
que vous avez un partenariat avec
microsoft xbox pour pouvoir venir jouer
aux jeux de xbox dans le cloud vous avez
plus de 90 jeu
de ce côté-là blé pouvoir jouer
également d'un évidemment avec les jeux
de dupes les stores mais ça augmente
vraiment expérience l'essai que vous
mettez votre smartphone là vous venez le
connecter sans fil à votre contrôleur
ils vont l'utiliser en mode game et
lydie qu une entreprise comme samsung
fasse un partenariat avec microsoft sur
l'idée du gaming sur l'idée du cloud
gaming
ça montre vraiment là où on va aller en
terme d'expérience de jeu au niveau du
club gagne irresponsable vraiment bien
alors le code gaming bien évidemment se
développe commence à se développer c'est
vachement intéressant et ça c'est
vraiment cool parce que ça montre
vraiment une fois de plus une vision de
l'avenir on va pouvoir se connecter dans
quelques années quand la 5g sera arrivé
chez vous eh bien vous pourrez jouer
partout facilement grâce à la 5g au clos
de gagner honnêtement on pouvait jouer
quand même enquête je pouvais jouer de
chez vous si vous avez de la fibre ça
sera là ce qu'il ya de mieux
vous pourrez également jouer en adsl il
ya pas mal de possibilités et je trouve
que l'idée est plutôt bonne
c'est tout le contrôleur pourra garder
voulait jeter un coup d'oeil plutôt
complet on a une vraie manette de jeu
avec vos boutons là vous venez
positionner votre smartphone ici bon ça
c'est plutôt bien on se retrouve avec
une grosse batterie de 4300 milliampères
heures dans le nord 20 et de 4500 mais
les empereurs dans le note 20 ultra bien
évidemment je donnerais le score du
résultat l'autonomie quand j'aurai fait
le test donc dans quelques jours donc
une fois de plus ne s'est pas déjà fait
vous toujours venir vous abonner en
appliquant son petit bouton rouge que
vous avez là d'ailleurs si les rouges
c'est que vous n'êtes pas abonné d'oka
lille gym puis cliquez vous avez de la
recharge rapide 25 watts vous permettra
de le recharger à 50% seulement 30
minutes vous avez également de la
recharge sans fil que ce soit sur le
note 20 ou sur le note 20 ultra c'est la
recharge 15 watts et vous avez aussi de
la recherche inversée pour venir charger
vos petits bugs l'idée du spn c'est bien
évidemment la productivité est
légalement il ya un partenariat avec
microsoft vous allez pouvoir notamment
celle des nouveautés cette année
exporter vos fichiers au format
powerpoint pour toutes vos présentations
vous avez également la possibilité de
venir
stockez vos notes dans le clos des les
récupérer que ce soit sur votre
smartphone ou votre tablette ou bien
votre pc très facilement le fm qu'est ce
qui peut apporter de nouveau qu'on
n'avait pas l'année dernière alors la
première chose c'est qu'on va avoir un
temps de latence qui est largement
améliorée oui puisque sur une note 10
ans gagne et on avait quarante cinq
millisecondes donnant de latence est à
dire quand quand vous allez toucher
l'écran cette activité qu'à votre écran
par rapport au fn
là on va passer à 9 millisecondes sur
notre vin ultra d'accord et 26 sur le
notebook d'accord donc ses conseillers
d'avoir considérablement améliorée et
quel bénéfice pour
tous fait record encore à écrire gb
d'avoir un produit dont le l'expérience
se rapproche de ce qu'on connaît sur
papier donc une approche beaucoup plus
naturelle beaucoup plus fluide comme sur
les crimes avec un stylo sur un papier
là tu vas d'adressé acquis avec ça en
fait tu vois le espagnol a peu fait
l'idée du professionnel alors ça peut
être le professionnel n'est pas
seulement parce qu'on constate
généralement c'est que les possesseurs
de galaxy note et sont très fidèles
william de produits parce qu'ils
notamment ils utilisent beaucoup leur
espèce
ça peut servir à des usages productifs
comme tu disais écrire sur de la prise
de notes
on va pouvoir prendre des notes et
enregistré 2 un texto du en même temps
et moi une note audio pardon donc voilà
pour des conférences des cours pour
transférer vers le manuscrit du
manuscrit par non vers le numérique
oui ça peut servir aussi aux créatifs à
toute la partie des cinq ans consistent
pas toujours on peut faire de véritables
oeuvres d'art
espn et apprendre à tout un tas d'usagés
qui sont sympas au quotidien comme
pouvoir traduire du texte où exactement
survolons avec son aspen prendre des
photos à distance avec le déclencheur
qui étaient ici jusqu'à jusqu'à 50
mètres en bluetooth donc
donc voilà tout ça c'est des usages qui
sont rendues possibles par le s pen et
aidons nos utilisateurs sont trop friand
vous êtes nouveaux usages du nouveau
geste aussi oui qu'on va pouvoir avoir
en plus pour rajouter à l'interaction à
l'expérience promet que cette année puis
on a tous les gestes qu'on connaît déjà
comme revenir en arrière revenir au menu
d'accueil
mais surtout on a la possibilité d'aller
configurer des commandes gestuelles sur
son espen alors je vais vous montrer où
c'est si on va dans fonctions avancées
et s pen on a une différente tous qu'ils
sont là et encore leur associer des
actions comme l'ouverture d'une
application par exemple ou de l'appareil
photo donc
imaginons que je sois quelqu'un comme
toi qui as envie de d'enregistrer des
notes vocales régulièrement je peut
configurer mon espèce sur un
enregistreur vocal comme ça quand je
vais faire un petit geste avec avec
celui ci j'ai cette application qui
sauvent directement j'ai pas besoin
d'aller la chercher dans dans mon tiroir
d'applications petites coupures problème
de batterie de mon micro il s'est arrêté
hier donc on reprend aujourd'hui aux
jours après mais c'est exactement la
même chose vous n'avez pas moins de cinq
nouveaux érection nouveaux gestes vous
allez pouvoir faire directement avec vos
galaxy note 20 note 20 ultra on voit
qu'on a des produits qui sont vraiment
dédié sur la productivité en plus vous
avez index sans fil vous allez pouvoir
utiliser votre smartphone comme un petit
ordinateur on voit qu'on a un outil qui
vraiment dédié à la productivité et qui
vous permettra d'aller plus loin sur des
tâches plus professionnelle ou en tout
cas même de productivité familiale un
autre mot qui est extrêmement important
dans cette gamme c'est toute la partie
photo vidéo où il ya un gros focus qui a
été fait de la part de samsung
alors vous avez deux confier différentes
entre le note 20 et le note 20 ultra
vous avez un triptyque grand angle ultra
grand-angle téléobjectif
on reçoit des deux côtés sur une note 20
vous avez un grand-angle de 64
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 1.8
un ultra grand-angle de 12 mégapixels
une ouverture de f 2.2 et un
téléobjectif de 12 mégapixels de
l'arthur de f 2.0 qui vous permettra
d'abord un zoom hybride x 3 et d'aller
jusqu'à x 30 grâce au space zone tandis
que son hôte invitera vous avez une
caméra grand-angle de 100 8 mégapixels
avec une ouverture de f 1.8 qui vous
permettra de regrouper 9 pixels en 1 et
notamment pour la photo de nuit pour
capter plus de luminosité vous avez
également ultra grand-angle de 12
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 et un tel
objectif de 12 mégapixels tout bref 3.0
et qui vous permettra d'avoir un zoom
optique x 5 est d'abord un space jusqu'à
x 50 et 100 modèles ultra vous allez en
plus une caméra tough petit laser qui
sera là pour la profondeur de champ pour
le mode portrait et sur les deux modèles
vous avez une caméra cette fille de 10
mégapixels et ouvre à f 2.2 tout ça bien
évidemment on va le tester d'ici
quelques jours quand le smartphone sera
arrivé pour les phases de test et je
vous dirais exactement ce que j'en pense
mais connaissant samsung ne connaissant
leur travail connaissant l intégration
logicielle et tout traitement qui fait
d'ailleurs au niveau des photos je ne
doute pas qu'on est vraiment une
excellente qualité sur ses galaxy note
20 la partie single take que je vous
avais présenté avec les galaxy s dans on
va la retrouver
on a des signes de l'apec un peu plus
long qui vont aller jusqu'à 15 secondes
ayant un gros focus qui a été fait sur
la vidéo en gros focus et ça c'est
vraiment intéressante pour toute la
partie création pour les créatifs si
vous voulez faire de la vidéo et vos
smartphones et bien on a une config est
vraiment intéressante grâce au galaxy
note 20 alors que ce soit sur un modèle
ou sur l'autre devrait pouvoir filmer
jusqu'à huit cas à 24 images par seconde
ici par contre vous aurez absolument
aucune stabilisation vous n'avez aucune
limite d'enregistrement en 8k et vous
allez voir même filmer au format 21 9ème
qui vraiment le format cinémascope si
vous souhaitez le faire vous pouvez
également filmé en 4k jusqu'à 60 images
par seconde et en full hd jusqu'à 120
images par seconde
permettra d'aller plus loin et notamment
au niveau des ralentis mais et c'est là
où c'est à dire extrêmement intéressant
que vous avez un mode vidéo pro qui vous
affichera notamment vu m pour votre
signal sonore vous avez également un
histogramme et vous pouvoir paramétrer
votre source audio soit vous allez
pouvoir paramétrer en omnidirectionnelle
donc vous allez capter le son qui vient
un peu partout devant derrière soi sur
l'arrière du smartphone si vous voulez
filmer quelqu'un qui en face de vous un
mode interview soit en face si vous
voulez vous filmez que vous voulez
vraiment capté quelque chose de très
directionnelle par rapport au son de
votre bouche soit grâce au bluetooth
notamment des petits galaxie buzz quel
qu'il soit vous allez pouvoir à les
utiliser en bluetooth
si par exemple vous les faire un
reportage filmé quelque chose et ne pas
utiliser le son du smartphone vous avez
à venir optimiser la qualité de votre
voix et même si vous mettez à distance
que vous posez votre smartphone vous
partez à quelques mètres vous vous
rapprochez vous marchez bien sûr
toujours une très bonne qualité sonore
donc ça s'est vraiment bien convoque un
gros focus qui fait sur les créateurs
sur la photo samsung excellent soit la
partie vidéo cherche vraiment
s'améliorer pour aller chercher toujours
plus les créatifs et je trouve ça
intéressant parce que ça montre vraiment
ce smartphone est vraiment là pour les
personnes qui aiment la création que ce
soit sur le dessin que ce soit sur la
photo que ce soit sur la vidéo on reste
une fois de plus dans l'idée de la
productivité on n'est pas que dans la
productivité professionnelle ou
familiale
on est dans la productivité dans la
création fin c'est vraiment un point
souligné parce que si vous voulez un
smartphone pour tourner des vidéos pour
faire de la photo eh bien pourquoi pas
et sur le galaxy note 20 ultra voir le
note 20 sinon vous ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire à noter qu'en plus
d'un truc qui est vraiment intéressant
en terme de vidéo vous avez le speed
zoom qui vous permettra de venir modules
et vesoul lorsque vous êtes en train de
filmer pour à quelque chose de très doux
et pas avoir un zoom petit peu saccadée
ça vous permet vraiment d'avoir des
transitions beaucoup plus douce ans vous
allez venir chercher à vous rapprocher
les zooms et dans l'image
bon pourquoi pas côté os voire très bien
évidemment au wan wide 2.5 basé sur un
android
10 c'est un smartphone qui est bien
évidemment du wifi 6 du bluetooth 5.0
une certification ip68 résistante à
l'eau et à la poussière et vous pouvez
précommander dès maintenant d'ailleurs
vous aimiez les liens en bas dans la
description et qui est disponible à
partir du 21 août prochain concernant
les tarifs sur le matin vous avez le
conflit
8 + 2 156 giga version 4g que vous
pouvez trouver au tarif de 9 159 euros
vous avez également la version 5 g + 2
156 gygax que vous retrouvez à 1059
euros et si vous voulez aller sur le
plus gros modèle le note 20 ultra la
bête
le smartphone le plus performant on est
uniquement sur de la 5g 12 plus 256 giga
de stockage extensible dans ce cas là et
bien vous êtes à 1309 euros et si vous
voulez aller sur la version 12 + 500 12
giga de stockage c'est beaucoup tra 1409
euros vous avez deux offres de
précommande une offre de précommande
gaming où vous allez avoir trois mois
offert au microsoft games passe plus une
manette + un chargeur sans fil ou alors
une offre de pré commandes audio 109,20
vous allez avoir des galaxies butts plus
offerts et pour le nôtre 20 ultra vous
allez avoir des galaxies boys live qui
seront également offerts voilà donc pour
ce produit il aurait eu plusieurs
annonces on en reparlera un petit peu
plus tard il y aura plein de tests
différence sur les différentes annonces
ont été faites aujourd'hui par samsung
la question à se poser c'est est-ce que
ce samsung galaxy note 20 ou 9 a eu
trois effet pour vous la question se
pose est bien évidemment sur le stylet
mais au delà du style et on le voit
c'est vraiment toute la partie créative
créateur parce qu'il ya plusieurs usages
effectivement la productivité familiale
professionnelle
on a effectivement tout la party games
inc un très très gros focus là dessus
mais la question basque vraiment splitté
et on en repart allant du test sur la
party gaming avec la partie club gaming
d'un côté la partie plus gaming un peu
plus traditionnel sur smartphone comme
on connaît avec le plextor bien
évidemment la meilleure expérience vous
l'aurez avec le modèle ultra parce que
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement de
120 hertz
on a deux produits qui sont donc
vraiment cool produits dédiés vraiment
multimédia avec une expérience est
complètement en acsi misez vous avez de
la performance ils font vraiment de très
belles promesses j'ai hâte de pouvoir
les tester pour vous dire concrètement
ce que j'en pense avec un retour sur
plusieurs jours avoue de manière vous
maintenant qu'est ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire est ce que vous
êtes tenté par ses deux nouveaux
smartphones de samsung galaxy note 20
galaxy note 20 ultra est ce que vous
êtes un peu déçu par le galaxy note 20
le dos plastique par un dos vert avec un
fort infléchissement de 60 earth pas de
90 hertz pas de 120 hertz et qu'est ce
que vous pensez de l'ultra est-ce qu'il
vous votre style vous hype
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter tu dois tout ce que vous en
pensez en bas que je vous dis on en
parlait ici quelques jours on parle bien
évidemment de tous les autres produits
ont les testera qui ont été présentés
par samsung parce que ya vraiment de
très très très très belles choses et
j'ai vraiment hâte de pouvoir vous dire
tout ce que j'en pense je vous invite
donc à venir tout ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire sur
l'ensemble des produits présentés quand
on se retrouve extrêmement rapidement
pour continuer par l'état qui croyez moi
croyez moi qui apple lancera contraste
beaucoup d'amour a très vite
m
[Applaudissements]